[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday guess
what we're doing hi you know the pizza
cocktail we're making some pizza
cocktails we're using my pizza John shot
glass and then this glass from the hotel
because Hank forgot his beads ajahn Chah
okay first I need some v8 juice some
vodka a mozzarella stick and pepperoni
the super modern take on the Bloody Mary
I hate Bloody Mary's by the way no me
too one of my least favorite some
cocktails you like tear it like this and
then put it on the rim of the glass no
mozzarella stick in the pepperoni I
think our mostly for garnish but you can
stir with the mozzarella stick as well
uh-huh that's bad I did know it tastes
good chaser microstrip pretty good
though all the stuff you don't want goes
in there boy that looks exactly like
puke our next cocktail is called the
tipsy John Green Hank I need some diet
dr. pepper and vodka so easy-peasy
pink that's good no good that's the best
i techgripper I've ever had
ah that's vodka ever had the old school
vlogbrothers joke it's equal parts
champagne dr. pepper and Strawberry Hill
but they didn't have stronger Oh so
we're going with Mike's strawberry
lemonade here's to the species
continuing into 2018 OOP small pleasures
really good amazing oh my god one of the
best champagnes I've ever had a plus
plus that's not the best way to have
diet dr. pepper the best way to have
Mike's Hard Lemonade and the best way to
have champagnes are you'll excuse me
while I pour myself another one how do
you make Ovaltine yes Hank our next
cocktail is called the Hank one-part
Strawberry Hill which in this case is
Mike's Hard Lemonade one part vodka and
one part Ovaltine because you made an
Ovaltine joke in the previous video so
you you're the reason we're in this
problem maybe I made a mistake beautiful
like striations and John's
look how pretty it is show it with the
pizza John out so people know that
there's value in that the remote control
all Cheers to town zones to calzones not
good it is a very good one it's called
keep it simple and it's just a shot of
bubbly water for yourself a double hey
Cheers
here's the Willis care a little scarier
long may he live hmm it might be my
favorite of the night Wisconsin
hey we were down to our last drink of
the 2017 eying like a g6 the guy who
created the periodic table also created
a bug he defined vodka since oh yeah he
was a Russian and and he created the
definition of what vodka was I think
we've gotta get to our last drink of
tonight which isn't it's called the
vlogbrothers classic okay it's
Strawberry Hill with a peep on top what
flavor do you want do you want
marshmallow ghosts or do you want spooky
cats just for future reference peeps
don't have flavor they just have shape
we not strawberry hell but we have
Mike's harder strawberry lemonade if you
weren't completely incapacitated by the
two and a half units of alcohol you've
had I mean you would understand the
incredible importance of pitching dftba
emerged during don't have to it's such
high quality stuff people will get it
brother we talked about it or not oh I
mean that was almost my favorite
drinking tonight Hank get a hold of
yourself for God's sakes the winner and
the person who's gonna receive all the
pizza Mesmer is the old school
vlogbrothers joke equal parts Strawberry
Hill Champaign and diet dr. pepper and
it was delicious I want to fill up
bottles with it and sell it on the black
market yeah I wouldn't go that far
Hank thank you for being here get some
rest and I will see you tomorrow